hello and welcome to the great energy
transition a new series from
Intelligence Squared in partnership with
Cummings this series is all about
bringing together leading voices
um to discuss the big questions around
the environment and energy and the
journey to Net Zero I'm Helen chersky
I'm your host and this is the middle one
in the series of three so our first was
about what's happening between now and
2030 to achieve Net Zero the final one
is about the role of corporations in the
energy transition and this one the
middle one is about the median term what
what needs to happen between 2030 and
2050 to achieve Net Zero and joining us
today is srikanth who is the vice
president at Cummings and president of
their engine business and we'll be
hearing Lots from him about the Cummings
view of what will happen between 2030
and 2050 and of course his broader views
on how to ensure a successful energy
transition and we've got lots to discuss
there's all these big questions you know
how do we think about these big
challenge is which Technologies are
going to be critical for this transition
what infrastructure is going to be
needed and how do we future proof it and
what other groundwork needs to be laid
so that we can really make this
transition effective you know the
groundwork for stuff that may not start
happening until a decade or so from now
so it is time to introduce Our Guest for
today in a little bit more detail um
shrikanth is a vice president at
Cummings and also as I said presidents
presidents of their engine business
which is the largest of Cummins business
segments and his focus is on positioning
codes as the leader leading powertrain
supplier across the full range of
options so they have currently Diesel
and natural gas and then hybrid and
electric powertrains and in 2021
um srikanth and his team were
responsible for an output of nearly 1.5
million engines globally so this is no
Small Change we're talking about here
and so he's got a very broad view of
this business
um so srikanth welcome to Intelligence
Squared thank you Helen thank you for
that nice introduction as well yeah
thank you I'm super excited to be here
yeah well let's say we'll get stuck
straight in with some some big thought
s so first of all you know the world is
is changing really quickly you know we
can see already the changes from year to
year are really coming fast so thinking
ahead to 2030 you know it seems a lot
might already have changed by then so
how does a business like Cummings you
know approach the planning what feeds
into it like how when in a world that's
changing so quickly how do you plan for
what's going to happen between 2030 and
2050.
yeah can I just take a step back just to
tell a little bit about uh both me and
the company as well I've been in the
company for well over 30 years and I've
been around the world I grew up in India
came to the United States then lived in
Mexico lived in England and came back
over here to the United States and this
company has been there for about 103
years so there are parallels from what
has happened in the last 30 years is
what the next 30 Years in some ways are
likely to be even though there might be
accelerated stuff that might happen I
think in the last 30 years I personally
have seen in commercial mobility and
transportation enormous amounts of
improvement that we've had so for
example today at 67 trucks today produce
the same emissions as one truck that
produced in 1988 which means that we
have made huge huge Improvement in
emissions and efficiency and things like
that which then makes me think that what
we are doing now in 2022 was what we set
the sage in 2013 if you will which means
for what needs to happen particularly
because reliability durability and other
things are important in the commercial
mobility and transportation space we're
pretty much getting started on what work
will get to go down the assembly line by
2030 or so so almost already if you have
not started doing some work today 2030
will pretty pretty soon be here so which
means for me to see what needs to happen
between 2030 and 2050 is long-range
scenario planning is one thing that we
do quite a bit in terms of what kind of
adoption rates for zero emissions
Vehicles might be whether it should be a
slow adoption it would be a fasted
option what kind of regulatory framework
that we would have from people in
Belgium some people in California people
in Beijing people in New Delhi as well
as in EPA if you will in the United
States and the last one would be what
kinds of government incentives and
others that are going to be there in the
political State work so it is public
private as well as regulatory framework
which is what will help us come together
to understand what can happen between
2030 and 40 which then allows our
technology planning and financial
planning as well
now I said
because I gave you one of your job
titles is president of the engine
division
many people see the road to Net Zero as
basically that's the getting rid of the
engines so
um how how does how does an engine
business approach any energy transition
are there going to be any engines in in
2030 or 2040 yeah and I think all of us
have come and given some major
pronouncements right the United States
has said 2050 the Euro zones have said
that China is at 2060 India is at 2070
these are all terminologies that are
there that people and countries would
want to get to that's Zero by some
particular time what I don't know I
think I know for sure is it's not a
light switch event which means things
are not going to happen overnight I just
recently visited India and I came back
from there those folks in terms of
development what it requires that needs
to happen over there would require
fertilizer would require steel would
require cement and would require
Plastics in terms of what they need to
do as development happens and for all
that in many ways what we do is Central
to it what I do know is there is going
to be a finite time period where I'll be
gone and this diesel engines may not be
there but in the meantime I think we
need to start today as opposed to
waiting for this perfect solution right
this is what I call as continuous
Improvement beats postpone Perfection
for me if we don't start today and we
make incremental improvements year on
year which is what I'm targeted to do
which is what we are going to do in
terms of the solutions that we provide I
think it is far better to do that than
waiting for some perfect Nirvana that is
going to happen in 2035 or 2045 and
hoping the world will be cured of all
its evils and things will get really
really better
well we'll come to some of those details
in technology in a little bit but I was
also um just in thinking of these these
kind of big strategic thoughts I was
interested in what you think the biggest
influences are in this transition to net
zero four for a company like Cummins
because obviously you know there's
always economics particularly at the
moment you know money is tight in many
places people don't have spare money to
buy new technology necessarily there's a
lot of public pressure there's probably
customer pressure there's probably the
communities where your production
facilities are who you know people are
starting to realize how important
talking to those communities is you're
known as government policy so there's
all these pressures on a big company
like Cummins where where are the real
drivers coming from for you to to get
you you know to shift your business to a
net zero situation yeah thank you I
think in the larger scheme like you said
it is the community it is the production
facilities that we do and it is what do
we do to take care of the communities
that we are in and how are we going to
provide employment and growth is one
aspect of it the larger piece though
what we do is the products in use is
what produces the carbon that we do
which means 99 of what we do is how do
we improve the products that we put out
there which produces lesser carbon this
comes from either environmental and
sustainability goals that people are
asking or for that matter these days
Financial regulatory pressures that we
have in terms of people asking us to do
better in terms of our sustainability
goals in which is one I'm very proud of
commences on the Forefront of many of
these and we did a lot of these things
long before it was a fad we went to
India in 1962 long before it was a fat
we started our sustainability report
long before it was if I had 25th 20
years ago or so and these are things
that we do because it makes right sense
that we and the community are symbiotic
in some ways that we have to do these
things right but the bigger picture is
at least as it relates to Commercial and
transportation in terms of commercial
Mobility most of these people that use
this use it for a living unlike you and
I using cars we could afford not to have
a car tomorrow and we could ask our
spouse or somebody else to drop us at
work whereas for these people what they
do matters in a serious way so what they
look for in some ways is will my total
cost of ownership be right will I be
able to will it economically make some
sense and at the same time do I have the
necessary infrastructure that is there
for me to use this because the gasoline
and the diesel infrastructure that has
been put in place over the last 100
years is being huge now to disrupt that
and being able to put back electric
networks or others that you need to have
the first thing that they ask us is do
you have the infrastructure that is
there can I do my job that I need to do
and will it make money for me these are
the three big drivers I get to hear
every day when I go to customers and
that's what forces them to make
decisions on one technology over the
other and the other thing they would ask
us is don't push me into one set of
Technologies allow me give me the
palette of technologies that is
available so that I can choose what is
best for me for the application or for
the use that I need to have
done that
of uh you know different users having
different needs and different priorities
Cummins is a global company so how does
this look across different continents
because as you said you know for us in
the industrialized West there is a
particular set of concerns here a
particular set of systems that are
already in place when you're looking at
the global business Commons has do you
see do you need a different strategy on
different continents or in different
regions and and what are the how how do
they differ
well in in lots of ways on two axes I
would say on one axis is what is the
horsepower if you will that you need to
do the work that you need to and for
those of you that have been in some
parts of the world you'll see these
buses and trucks that are driving at 10
miles an hour it feels like on first
gear because of how the infrastructure
on the road is there right in which case
there what you would consider as a 200
horsepower motor that you would probably
call it as medium duty in North America
would be heavy duty in India for that
matter or in Africa for that matter the
other thing for example most of our
combines and agricultural Equipment
Works for about 300 hours in any given
year in places where there is these land
masses are not available for you to do
agriculture most of these equipments are
very very small if you think of it so
one is average that you use from 300
hours to six thousand hours that you
would do on the other side is in terms
of horsepower as to what is the power
that I require for the work that I need
to do so any so you can't just in one
Big Blob say it's Transportation
Mobility you divide this up into
hundreds of applications and each of
these applications by region by the
geography that you're operating in by
the customers that they use tend to
become very different which is why I
call Commercial mobility and
transportation is a marsh shot as
opposed to passenger car is a moon shot
I would say because you can actually get
it done because the user's similar and
the way people use it is pretty much
around the world very very similar
okay well again we'll come just before
we get to the Technology Center let's
come to the goals because
um you know Cummins has set out these
this road map but to tell us what it is
like you know there's all these
companies at the moment and everyone's
got their policy and their strategy and
they're wherever
um there's all these buzzwords that kind
of go round and round and I'm never sure
how much some of them mean but what what
for coming specifically what are the
goals in terms of Net Zero and
sustainability yeah we've said that
publicly we've said by 2015 we've been
at zero what that means for us in terms
of Net Zero is net zero in the
operations that we participate in which
is factories distribution centers and
others in terms of life cycle what do we
do in terms of the products that we use
in these places as well as in the
communities that it impact in we would
make sure that it is net zero the other
large part that we have said is that the
products that we use that go into use
with our customers would be Net Zero by
2050. I think of this in three segments
or three chunks of 10 years Helen the
first 10 would be where everybody is
trying out a variety of Technologies
which is what people are going to say
I'm going to try one of these one of
that and I'll see what works which is
what we are in which is predominantly at
this time I would call it as a prototype
mode most of it is still Diesel and
natural gas but any of these other
Technologies are just you're trying as
Alpha phase or beta phase that you would
do at this time people are also starting
to think about what infrastructure can
be there to be this green infrastructure
that we could have because well to
Wheels is hugely important for us
meaning from well to tank and then tank
to wheel right tank to wheel is what
everybody talks about but if you cannot
grain the grid then what you get in
terms of you might be driving an
electric car in Indiana where I am from
but most of the source of that power
that comes from is coal which doesn't
necessarily help from a well-to-wheel
perspective so infrastructure will start
to go on green the second phase which I
call is the messy middle which would be
the 30s to 40s would be where certain
technologies will Bubble Up which will
then allow you to say this is better
from a total cost of ownership from a
customer use or from where people need
to be doing these things and then at the
same time in my opinion infrastructure
will start getting better in this time
the last decade in 2040 is where I think
reliability of the grid will be better
in terms of the green grid and even if
it is not exactly 2050 this three-phase
philosophy of prototype trying as many
solutions messy metal and robust
solutions that come up in the last
decades is how I think this will start
to pan out and again this is different
for different parts of the world like
you said in some parts of the world it
may not be possible by 2050 that they
could do well to wheel they might do
tank to wheel first before they could go
well to Tanked
and how does this I mean so one thing
that's very you know it's starting to be
talked about more it was one kind of
achievement I guess in the public
discussion to get to Net Zero by some
date but obviously you know the
environmental science the earth science
is very clear that there is a big
difference between doing 95 of the work
in the first five years and then kind of
tidying up the rest until 2050 and then
just kind of leaving everything as it is
until you know five years before the
deadline and then trying to do it all
right at the last minute and and it's
clear that the more we do earlier the
better it's going to be so so how is
that built into Cummins goals because
you know it's one thing to say we can
kind of follow the market and do what
everyone else does and it's all going to
get better but there is a big difference
between dropping things very quickly at
the start and kind of saving up the big
gains until the end yeah which is what
we call as destination zero right and
then this idea of that we have two kinds
of businesses that we have one is this
existing business that you talk about
which is the ice business internal
combustion engine and the other one that
we have within our company which is this
new power business that we have the idea
is that you need to advance new Power
Solutions as though there is it is going
to happen today in those applications
that you can actually get zero emissions
vehicle today while at the same time if
you can improve the efficiency of
existing applications and going and
putting requirements like we have said
that from 2018 time frame by 2030 we
will reduce it by 25 which means that
for every vehicle that is out there we
can actually reduce the emissions that
is being produced right one good example
that I would argue is for example if you
put in drop-in fuels in our engines that
are there today like renewable natural
gas is a good example that you would
have it's negative carbon not only do
you do that but you do it not for
existing engines but for all the engines
out there that is already there you
would be able to put that in which means
that you're starting to reduce the
carbon footprint that you've put out
this is why I think our approach of
doing both is actually better than
waiting for this perfect solution that
you're saying either at 20 45 or 2040
and then say everything will go till
that time don't do any Improvement on
the existing things which requires
though that we have to invest quite a
bit on both kinds of Technologies which
is why companies like us can afford to
do because we have the scale not
everybody could afford to do it some
people can do the one side of it which
is the new power that I'm going to go
battery electric like Tesla is doing or
some others can just say I'm going to
abandon this I'm just going to do one of
this kind and leave it there we have the
scale we have the geography reach and we
are able to actually do this which I
think is far better approach than one or
the other
so you're just I mean because a lot of
uh you know sort of environmental
discussion at the moment is very hard on
any investment in in diesel engines for
example so am I right in thinking here
that your justification is that the
infrastructure doesn't exist for
something else for now so you make the
diesel engines better while you can
expecting that to be overtaken yeah I I
think it is exactly that but then even
more so that every Improvement that you
make today is actually going to help in
the long run as Technologies get firmed
up it's not only in diesel right natural
gas it's a lower carbon fuel if you can
use bio renewable fuels that you could
put in diesel which allows you today
let's say 20 of what you do is biofuels
and if you care capable of using 100 of
our engines to be 100 capable of
renewable fuel which we don't sometimes
today not all manufacturers do then your
light allows that synthetic fuel is the
other one that you would do natural gas
is one propane is the other as well as
hydrogen if you can develop a hydrogen
economy as one example till such time
fuel cells are ready which is going to
be quite a while away particularly in
the commercial transportation space if
you can use hydrogen as a fuel in the
existing engine that you have then you
can actually gain a lot of benefit over
the next decade or so till such time
fuel so already that's our approach to
say start today don't wait it's not a
light switch event it's going to take
some time can you do something in the
meantime while you're getting ready for
that hybrids is another case where
batteries eventually it'll go to
batteries but if you could put with the
existing diesel motor an electric motor
and 20 percent of that power can come
from the electricity electric motor that
you have that's 20 percent less use of
existing diesel fuel that you would use
in there which overall helps with less
carbon that's going into the atmosphere
and what you see in the wide you know
with your competitors effects of The
Wider world because it's fine you know
Cummins is a big company but still it's
not the only company and and I'm
interested in your perspective on on the
general movement because it has been
traditionally the case especially in
things like engines the sort of more
traditional forms of engineering perhaps
that they have been a little bit slower
to accept that you know if you if you're
on a startup and you've invented it you
invented a widget five years ago then
you're quite happy to invent another
widget in five years time right but
these traditional Industries do you see
urgency here
I I would say in the last five years the
world has changed quite a bit Helen I I
don't know if I sat in front of you in
2016 I would have been able to have this
much conviction about what I am talking
about at the time I would have been a
little bit tepid about what things are
where things are going the thing that
I'm seeing is there is still a group of
people whether call it uh on the one of
the ends of the spectrum where they
think that there is only this is the
only solution that is available and
these are the ones that are going and
talking about what they have I think in
general a little bit but most of our
competitors and customers whether it's
Daimler whether it is in China or in
India and other places that we have or
partners and customers that we have I
think senior Council has prevailed and
people in general agree that we need to
move towards battery electric we need to
move towards a hydrogen economy and
there is a bridge period by which that
we need to make Improvement today and we
cannot put our head in the sand and just
assume things are going to be the same
when we wake up 25 years from now or so
and that I'm seeing more and more I
speak to most ctOS and CEOs of these
companies and in general people feel
like we as a transportation and Mobility
industry can actually come up with the
Technology Solutions that need to be
there but if infrastructure is not there
and government incentives are not there
these three things need to coexist
together Technologies can come together
but most times why Technologies don't
get adopted is because infrastructure
may not be there at the same Pace as
which technology gets to be ready
and then how about measurement because
it's I mean it's one thing and we're
seeing this a lot at the moment in the
environmental space that companies make
a lot of claims of various types because
you know firstly because they want to
look good but it's kind of easy to make
a claim it's a lot harder to prove that
you've actually done the thing you know
especially in this kind of world where
you're you're kind of measuring a it's
not easy to show you didn't do something
you know so so what kind of metrics like
have you got a system of accountability
basically where you can be held to a
standard by you know your shareholders
or the public or your customers
yeah we were one of the first companies
to do what we call a science-based
targets right these are National Labs
and others Department of energy and
others that are approved mechanisms by
which they say this is how we measure
your CO2 footprint whether it is in your
factories or when your communities or in
your products that you use and then what
is your Baseline and where are you going
from there but there is lots of this
that everybody wants to claim that I'm
improved by 20 or are approved by 30 the
one thing that is happening in the
United States particularly is this SEC
rules that are likely to come up which
might actually Force us to do some of
this which is what I think around the
world over time might come about that
might make it the other thing which I
don't think is very popular but
eventually if there is some sort of a
carbon credit system that will be there
then I think this measurement system is
going to get really really good because
of the fact that you're going to get
credit for something that you're doing
and people are going to get real and see
if they're going to get money out of the
whole transactions us if you will that I
think that will also Force this
accounting to be okay I think
well it's I mean not um I think the next
question about all of this you know in
five years time we're going to be
sitting here discussing monitoring and
verification uh and that will be the big
topic you know can you prove it so
you've mentioned
um a couple of times different
Technologies
um how
you know how much is this a technology
problem and how much is it a a thinking
problem like it's our an attitude an
approach problem like and how much is it
just we haven't invented the widget yet
yeah I don't know maybe I am just
old-fashioned I think physics only goes
at a certain level that it can go right
is that you can't sometimes Force these
Solutions as though it is ready and
you'll pay for it in one form or the
other particularly in the kind of the
world that we are in in commercial
transportation you can't just go and put
a product out there that would not
necessarily work or it works for a
little bit and then it goes away right
physics will take its own course and I
think most solutions that are there we
kind of know none of the things that I
am seeing today are new technologies
that has not been there fuel cells has
been there for a while for spacecraft
we've used fuel cells electric stuff is
not new it's 150 years old right and
we've used that some of the things that
we're talking about in terms of
renewable fuels and others I think it
has been there the biggest thing Helen I
would argue is the political will
and the collective will of Nations and
individuals together is what was lacking
even 10 15 years ago and somebody asked
me last week what are you optimistic
about and I think I take you from social
revolutions or social things that have
happened in the last 30 years or so if
those things can happen in my opinion
this thing will happen I don't think
this train has left the station I'm not
worried about it it will get to its
destination which is destination zero
the question is how will the path be is
what I don't exactly know but in 10
years time I think it'll get much more
crystal clear I would say
and so what do you see at the moment so
let's pick two of the the powertrain
options that are non-well we can argue
about the first one uh in theory could
be non-fossif fuel based uh and and
those are hydrogen and electric now
hydrogen is
um controversial because it's not
efficient as a fuel you know that you
can if you use electricity to make it
you get a lot less back than you put in
but it's portable you know it has some
of the advantages of a fossil fuel and
it can use that infrastructure so so
those two things specifically hydrogen
and electric have you got any feel for
which one of them might be more
important in some situation like how do
you plan basically how do you plan as a
business for for you know covering all
your bases here yeah let me take
electric for example right electric the
biggest issue that we have today is one
is cost obviously the cost of battery
which is coming down significantly the
second is energy density right which
means what is the size and weight of
this battery that is needed to be there
particularly in your best car it doesn't
matter you could put a 300 kilowatt
battery in there and you're using it for
three passenger or five passenger at
best and you'll have enough space where
you could put the battery if you got to
put the same thing on a truck you might
take one third of the truck or the Lorry
that you're going to be using where it
needs to transport Goods which makes it
difficult which is what we call as
energy density the second thing is today
most of us fill our petrol or gasoline
tanks in less than five minutes
for the same thing the energy density
it's 100 times more it takes for it to
get charged which means that for a
equivalent energy that you can get out
of diesel or gasoline fuel it would take
eight hours if you will for the five
minutes that you do which is what needs
to happen through superchargers and
infrastructures where you can actually
get it done either in the night when you
go back to a Depot like a school bus or
a Transit bus that you would have or for
that matter a few trucks that you go and
pick up garbage you come back and then
you can charge it and then you can start
back again the next time those are kinds
of applications or yard spotters in
places where it is or in in a port if
you want to go pick up stuff and then
put these cargo stuff back where other
trucks come and pick it up there are
those kinds of applications where you
can actually charge it and your range is
much less then those are the places
where electric will eventually pick up I
would argue now where hydrogen like you
said the issue has been if it gets
renewable meaning from when the Nella
solar is what you put or from
hydroelectric or others that you provide
this because I think we should just
clarify here that I think 95 of current
hydrogen supplies are actually leftovers
from the fossil fuel industry so this is
where the debate comes from that at the
moment hydrogen is not particularly
green but you can make it from
sustainable sources exactly if you do it
from sustainable sources then green
hydrogen is the best thing that you
could do because of the portability that
you talked about whether it is in some
parts of the world they think it needs
to be liquid in other parts of the world
we think it is gas that has not been
necessarily determined Europe likes it
because they would like to get ammonia
from other places which allows you then
it to be liquid whereas in U.S there is
already places where we have this
infrastructure in petrochemicals and
others that if you could sequester the
carbon which then becomes gray hydrogen
which then could eventually get to
become this green hydrogen that you have
then you could use the pipelines that
you're talking about that currently uses
which then allows for hydrogen as a good
Transportation mechanism the thing why
High hydrogen is good Helen in my
opinion is hydrogen is used in steel
hydrogen is used in cement production
hydrogen is used in petrochemical
production which means they have today
the infrastructure that is required by
many of these companies that are there
shall ramco Saudi aramco and all these
guys use hydrogen today and for them it
actually makes it easier as well that
they could do the other is materials
that are used for the creation of
batteries right lithium Cobalt nickel
all these things are sometimes not easy
to find and the amount of energy that
you need to put in the creation of
battery also makes it hard sometimes for
you to actually look at the
well-to-wheel use of it right which are
which is the other bit that you can
think so back to transportation and
Mobility back to what I'm good at and
what I know about I think it will be
based on application for short haul in
City applications with a return to Depot
battery electric will be the ones that
would go for Long Haul
a long distance commuting if hydrogen
can become the source of fuel it would
be much easier because of the fact of
transportation and how long it can
actually go and it'll allow you to use
the space and cargo that is required for
movement of goods as well
and so for for coming specifically then
what what are the technological sort of
and the engineering really advancements
that are your focus now I mean you know
we've talked about this we're looking
ahead to 2030 but presumably anything
your engineer now is only going to be
ready in by 2030 so what are the things
that are really like where your your
focusing effort now yeah I'll break it
down into three or four things right in
electric stuff it is more about the fact
what is battery cell chemistry
electrochemistry of batteries how do we
put these things together battery cells
into battery packs and what is the
electronics behind it in terms of
working through all this how does this
work so the software side of it how does
this battery charge and decharge those
kinds of things is what the technology
that needs to be proven out and that
needs to become really stable on the
fuel cell and the hydrogen side of it it
is the production of hydrogen in some
ways which is the electrolysis that we
are participating in it is as well the
fuel cell technology itself as to how do
these membranes work how does it not
leak how is it reliable and what do we
need to do and then the size needs to
come down so that we can actually put
this under the hood of a truck if you
will on the internal combustion engine
side it is more of the same if you will
on efficiency of diesel engines how do
we use our diesel engines to use
different fuels like hydrogen like
natural gas and others and then the
other piece of work that we are trying
to work on is these low carbon fuels is
there a real thing on low carbon fuels
because if you have the green Aviation
it's going to be synthetic fuel that you
got to do kerosene will not do it today
and if you need to move from kerosene to
the zero fuel zero carbon fuel then most
of the synthetic fuel is going to go
over there in which case can we have
renewable fuels like natural gas and
others that we could do which means that
our infrastructure around that needs to
change also in terms of how do you carry
it how do you transport it how do you
provide the delivery of this into the
engine and what do you need to do so
fascinating work which is why I think
that even though a lot of people think
that it's not a fascinating industry
what we are doing is just cutting edge
in my opinion it's not just always in
Silicon Valley that you do Cutting Edge
work we do it in Midwest of Indiana as
well well I think actually I mean one of
the interesting things about this this
whole transition is that the things that
matter most are not the sexy things in
the traditional way of thinking about it
and almost that's the biggest problem
like sure you know someone wants to
build a space rocket it's very cool
hooray but actually that is not we don't
need space Rockets we need very mundane
technologies that work very well and
they're much less you know you don't get
you don't get them featured on the front
of Technology magazines in quite the
same way do you ever do you ever feel
kind of un you know sort of
unappreciated in that way yeah it is but
then I've grown in this company which is
being called as a quiet company right
I've not talked to one like you in 30
years that I've been in right and
sometimes we just don't we just do our
job and hoping that we somebody will
notice it and somebody will recognize it
and that's good enough for us and I
often when I came in here that said hey
if you don't want your mom to know about
what's going to be on the papers on
Monday don't do it that's kind of how I
grew up in and so it just seems like I'm
old-fashioned in some ways yeah
uh my mum's on Twitter she knows
everything I I wanted to ask you
um about the ground laying the
groundwork because along with technology
that perhaps isn't terribly sexy to some
people
um there's a lot of you know if you want
to scale things up if you want to change
your whole system there's a lot of
things you need to start doing 10 or 15
years before you're really going to use
them and and so there's a lot of Forward
Thinking here and also it's a bit of a
bet because you perhaps don't know
exactly what is going to be needed so I
was just wondering what what do you see
in that space you know what needs to be
done now to make sure things can happen
in 2030 and how do you future proof the
effort that you put into it yeah I I
tell you the G20 is actually meeting in
Bali right now I think uh the top 20
Nations and somebody said this which I
think would be nice if that 10 of those
20
if they can get their act together
and you know all these players that are
there
that is probably the biggest thing that
we could do yeah I can recycle yeah I
can do simple things that I should do I
should be doing but the bigger thing
that can have the system of system
things that you're talking about is if
those 10 countries can come together and
make some meaningful things that we
could do that would work the second is I
would argue that Walking The Halls of
Washington DC Belgium and some of these
important players is important because
they have to go and do important things
just like they did the inflation
reduction act recently the things on the
chips act they did these are kinds of
things that they can in one swoop make
huge Investments for the future in terms
of Greening stuff either on the
infrastructure side or on the technology
side the third thing that I would say is
that as Industries come together I think
we need to think about our industry but
meaningful Solutions and put realistic
goals and make that happen if each of us
can do meaning that the fertilizer
industry can do that the steel
production industry can do that
electricity generation can do then
collectively governments and Regulatory
Frameworks can come together to go make
this happen the last one which is
important I think regulation plays
actually an important piece that is long
that is set set in goals and say that
there is Improvement that is going to
happen year on year over the next 15
years that will set the industry up well
for them to go do as well the last one I
would say is in some ways there is this
VC and the other infrastructure that is
there where money can go where it needs
to go I think there are a lot of people
that are doing those kinds of things in
terms of putting Venture Capital Fund in
some of these early stage technologies
that are there and collectively I think
those four things could actually make a
meaningful impact I would say
and so what's it to sort of pick up on
the first one there what do you think is
the balance between
the need for some kind of
standardization because in the long term
it's more efficient if everyone is using
the same kind of pipes or the same kind
of you know all of us have got computer
connectors of 37 different types hanging
around from the last 15 years right but
in order to have some kind of
standardization everyone has to agree on
a technology quite early and so there's
this thing where everyone's like they're
trying things out we've got all these
different things we all want to have our
own solution but at some point what the
world wants is just one kind of plug or
one kind of pipe
how how do you how do we balance that
how do how do you see the risks of
when do we have to choose okay we've had
our experimentation now we have to pick
we're just going to commit to this one
because in the long term that will be
more efficient even if in the short term
it's less efficient
yeah and I think one example if there is
one that is in front of our eyes is the
passenger car right I think a lot of
experimentation was going on for quite a
while in terms of plug-in hybrid series
hybrid in terms of fuel cells like the
Toyota Mirai Hyundai and others have
done GM has done and I think it is going
almost close to enough we're now going
to be battery electric for passenger
cars I think that's why I call that a
moonshot that it is more or less coming
there in the next three four years I
think that will be decided whether
you're going to be in India whether
you're going to be in China it is going
to be more or less electric I think on
the commercial side of it or for that
matter on steamships as to where or
ships that are going where it needs to
be or Aviation we still are not there at
that stage where passenger car is in the
next five to ten years probably I think
that sector will be there the same thing
will happen in steel the same thing will
happen in fertilizer each of them this
is why I think physics can only take
certain role you can't just fast forward
or just hit the fast forward button and
hopefully you'll get to the end and
hopefully we'll get there in the next
five years or so
we can
um and I I the question I'm going to
pick first is actually first on the list
here which is from Mahesh nagesh um and
it's about the cost of destination zero
on end consumers and the question is
will the common person end up digging
deeper into his pockets to achieve this
destination obviously there's a concern
about developing countries where a
larger section of people may not be able
to afford the cost of green and
sustainable living so how does how is
the cost of this distributed
yeah and I I don't know I'm not going to
make a political statement here but I
think ultimately
some of us have to pay for the others
and when I say some of us it is going to
be in some ways
disproportionately that the people that
have don't ever want to pay anything for
what they use I think or what they get
take for granted which is why I think in
some ways carbon credits or others that
are there will have to somehow
somebody has to pay for it and that is
how it's going to get distributed within
Nations and it's not going to be from
Nation One Nation to the other there
might be some ways by which that we will
redistribute it but for the most part I
think within localities and within other
places is how things things are going to
be paid for I would say because if you
want the comforts you have to pay for
some of these Comforts as well but at
the same time I understand maharish's
point which is hey in the development
world the developing world we do want to
develop life cannot be the same way it
is and we're not even asking for us UK
like gdps right if India and Africa and
Southeast Asia need to just get to
China's GDP levels
development needs to happen and if that
development needs to happen it has to be
sustainable or else we don't have an
earth that we can wait for for our
grandkids which then is the other side
of the equation right so I think there
is going to be some Reckoning that will
happen Helen in my opinion that'll be
the equivalent of carbon credits that'll
come in some form it is a taxation
somebody is going to pay for the
taxation the problem is how will we
communicate that and how will it be
palatable for people but in a
generation's time I believe that it'll
become quite palatable as opposed to now
well of course this is the big
discussion at cop27 which is going on as
we record this
um which that we're a huge part of that
is about who pays for what and loss and
damage and these big questions that are
being taken seriously this time when
they haven't been before okay right so
um
there's a question here about
um sort of regions I guess so the
question which is synonymous is uh
between America and Europe in Europe and
I guess we could include other
continents
who do you think is is remotely on route
to reaching Net Zero is anyone who's
going to get there first and is anyone
really gonna do it
yeah I I don't know whether it's a
region for example U.S has reduced it by
28 in the last 20 years in terms of
these carbon intensity Germany has done
it about the same amount Germany took a
different approach in terms of wind and
other power that they would do and
natural gas was the way by which United
States did in the last 20 years I think
technology forcing Solutions are not
necessarily always the right thing but
then there will be regions I think there
will be a Japan Korea region that will
be in Euro region there'll be a U.S
region that will happen then there'll be
Middle East China will be by itself and
India has to do itself and then there
comes southeast Asia and Africa I think
the bits of Technology when you go into
Europe it feels like that there is no
tomorrow you don't see that necessarily
in the U.S when you are out here because
of the distances to cover and some of
the attitudes that people have as well
and you will see if you've lived in
Germany you would know the amount of
recycling that goes on over there versus
what happens in the United States and
there is some cultural elements to it
that will also come into play I think so
each of these regions will come in its
own way but like you said or some you
said earlier that it'll eventually kind
of come to this electrical socket thing
that you're talking about that over time
it'll probably stabilize itself out I
think the cultural differences of one of
the most interesting aspects of all of
this and even just mentioning things
like
um bikes or electric cars you get such
different reactions in different
countries for such completely different
reasons you know it it varies a lot so
we've got there's a question here from
uh timoth backer about
um not just the different regions but
you know so if some summer gets some are
going to reach these goals before others
and the question from timoth is hey you
know how do we start working then with
other regions to help them you know so
India has a 2070
goal for example when the ones who get
there faster you know achieve their goal
earlier are they then you know should
they then work to help the other to help
bring the others forward
I think if capitalism works the right
way if it is benevolent I think it'll
happen because I think people will start
finding a way by which that there are
clever solutions that has allowed some
of these things to happen and I can
actually go and apply it to around the
world which is kind of how companies
like us have grown right we've gone
taken globalization in a way as much as
it is in a selfish way that we've taken
it along the way we've also found some
altruistic needs that we have actually
done in these places as well right and
so I think there will be that that will
happen that if there is a technology
that comes about or if there is
something that as a country we are doing
better my senses people would want to go
and Export it to other places I would
think which will hopefully help the
other countries as well
and of course that's the part of the
question of responsibility I guess is
you know to the the the more developed
countries have the means to help the
less developed countries
um so we've got a question here an
anonymous one and you sort of touched on
this but I'm going to ask the question
as it's written which is do you see any
I don't know why it's all about moon and
Mars but do you see any moonshot or Mars
shot Technologies being developed at the
general public don't know about but that
could be game changers in terms of
reducing carbon and I think they mean
reducing carbon intensity
well I I don't know in general but then
as it relates to commercial
transportation
some of the technologies that we are
doing is it's actually in the details is
what people don't know right is that as
we try to do emissions reduction some of
the stuff is not just Global CO2
reduction but locally we need to be
taking care of pollution in inner cities
if you will or in disadvantaged places
to do that actually work is pretty hard
it's not easy to go already we've
reduced it by 95 since where it was in
2000 and now we're asking it to get
further down because in certain
non-attainment zones like California or
in Atlanta or in New Delhi or other
places that are there we need to reduce
further for which there are technologies
that we are developing and others are
developing that probably is not yet come
public because of the fact that it is
still in the early stages of development
work hydrogen is another one I think
there is a lot of work that needs to be
done both on the electrolysis side of
things on the various technologies that
need to go high temperature how would we
do some of these things which will take
some time for it to come about as well I
don't know much about petrochemicals and
other areas of industrial production
good stability is another place where
there's a lot of good work that is going
on grid Greening is another place where
I think there is quite a bit of
Technology that's going on so if you
think about this entire well to wheel
and if you divide it into sections or
segments my census there is good bit of
technology that still needs to happen
but the biggest one Helen I would say
chemistry electrochemistry of batteries
if it can significantly improve in
energy density I think that would be the
game changer that we could have because
we don't have that today to get to where
we need we've improved it no doubt but
it needs to improve another 100 times
more on energy density if that does then
your question of is the electrical
socket question being clear it'll be
clear I don't think we're there yet on
energy density I would say
well one of the wonderful things about
batteries is that no one really
understood them before and they're
suddenly becoming this very complicated
topic and definitely nobody understands
them now but it is very important so
there's an interesting question here now
we haven't talked so much about
communities and people but there's an
anonymous question here about
um how are the future Technologies or
goals described changing or have already
changed the workforce so what does it
mean for the people working either to
make these Technologies or who are
working using these Technologies what's
The Human Side of all of this
yeah particularly from the operation
side of things right in the shop floors
that you do and others we talk about the
fact that a car that would have only 30
percent less moving parts now as opposed
to what in the internal combustion
engine world which means that we need to
figure out ways by which that we can
provide employment for these people and
retrain many of these people so that's
an important thing it is going from a
mechanical world to an electrical world
it is going from a world that will not
break down as much will break down
versus to a world that may not break
down as much in terms of both service
side of things as well as in the
production side of things we need to
retrain people the other thing that is
happening I think it is changing into a
lot more into an electrical world as
much as it has been a mechanical World
which means again retraining of the
workforce needs to be there and in many
companies including ours we can have a
university-like system where you can
take these courses that you potentially
could change as long as you're a problem
solver you'll find places where you
could go apply yourself now communities
this is the same thing like there are
communities that are going to be
completely different just like the steel
industry was there and Pittsburgh was
there and Gary Indiana was there when
you go to those places now things have
changed some cities have adopted better
adapted better than other cities which
means then again public private
infrastructure needs to come in which is
a 30-year 40-year Journey that we need
to take in today as opposed to thinking
tomorrow it's going to happen and we
need to change which we cannot change
once it comes to that stage
these are I think this is one of the
things that doesn't get discussed often
enough actually that question of you
know it's great to help people but if
you take their jobs away from them
because the new technology doesn't
require it not you're not really helping
them that much
um so there's a question here from James
short uh for Rural and underdeveloped
countries how do you see ice so that's
internal combustion engines being
replaced by Electric without an electric
infrastructure because of course in this
country we take it for granted that you
know there's wires everywhere and pipes
everywhere and we can just plug into
things how how does this work for
countries that don't have that yet
yeah good good example is India right
which is part of the reason why I think
when you talk about 2070 people kind of
say hey why is it 2070 it's this
infrastructure that you're talking about
they have brownouts on a regular basis
where they don't have electricity for a
couple of hours in a day or something
like that now India has been doing quite
a bit on renewable because of the fact
that they have 335 days in sun which
means they could do solar and wind and
solar prices have come down
significantly because of the investment
that China has made in the last 10 years
or 15 years where it used to be a
monopoly of the Western World now it is
a monopoly of the Chinese World in terms
of the solar photovoltag cells that are
there so in some ways renewable energy
is probably what is going to help some
of these places but it's going to take
some time before you can do which is why
it is not a light switch event Helen
it's going to take some time and in some
of these places it's just hard to Abate
Industries or just plain hard to just
say Okay overnight you go but that said
two wheelers and three wheelers are
going Electric in India in like nobody's
business and they've just overnight
transformed that place and thinking how
did this happen and so it just is
contrast to the land of contrast I guess
in some places that's what is going to
happen I think I see that in Africa
happening as well in terms of electric
scooters and electric three-wheelers
that are going to make that happen as
well well I guess the interesting thing
about the scooters and the e-bikes is
that you you can have you can have a
bottom-up approach as well as a top-down
approach you know if you want to
something that's going to rely on
hydrogen infrastructure and all of these
big things that has to come from a
company first but you know
I I have interviewed makers of electric
bikes who just started off in their
garage they were like oh I can do better
I'm going to fiddle around they make a
bike they start a company and then
there's electric bikes you know I guess
you need a bit of both
um yeah for sure
and so we have another question about
infrastructure here which is sort of
about the cost of the infrastructure and
how much Cummins is involved there's
sort of two questions into one here
really that both the cost of its
infrastructure and you know his Cummings
involved in building it and what sort of
because infrastructure is this very
vague word right that can it sort of
means everything but specifically what
sort of infrastructure do you think is
is
um needed and is it expensive how much
is this going to cost just the
infrastructure side of it
yeah trillions of dollars and I think
it's trillions of dollars on a sustained
basis is what needs to happen on
infrastructure right it's not today but
it is every year from now on that you
need to do there's a good Princeton
study Helen that people put together
just for the us alone that what do you
need to spend between 2022 or 2020
whenever it came out to 2050 for us to
be net neutral and the biggest portion
of the money that needs to come is from
infrastructure now when you think about
infrastructure it's electrical grid
infrastructure that you're talking about
it is transmission portion of it it is
the grid
good itself if you will on the hydrogen
side of it it is both the production of
hydrogen the transportation of hydrogen
and the ability to dispense it at those
places where you need it to be is also
infrastructure work we participate in a
very very small way we're just getting
started on the hydrogen pieces of it in
terms of electrolyzer and producing
green hydrogen we are starting to dabble
along in terms of infrastructure what
can we do of good storage and energy
storage systems and others that we need
to do but this is where big utility
firms and big players that are already
existing have to come in in a big way as
well and that Princeton study is a good
study which tells you how much you need
to do now each of these countries have
kind of come up with the same thing I
just recently saw a McKinsey study about
what does it take for India to do the
India alone needs 12 trillion dollars
between now and 2030 or something
that's the kind of investment that
you're talking about that you need to go
make and each country needs to make that
kind of investment
so there's another question here and I'd
like extend it a lot so the question
says and there's no name um will
governments really get on board for
example California says we want all
electric cars but then the next week
they tell the few people with electric
cars not to charge them and obviously
what's going on here is that there is a
shortage of electricity you know in in
California at the moment for various
reasons and so people are like okay well
I've got my I did what you told me I got
my electric car and now the
infrastructure isn't ready for it and
now you're telling me not to use it so
you know how how much of a problem is
this going to be yeah this is why some
Grand pronouncements like that to get it
out up by 2035 or we will be getting the
grid to be green by that time sometimes
it's just hard to go make happen if
governments are not willing to go make
the necessary investment right and so
this is going to be hard I don't that's
that political will
let me tell you this way I I think even
on the right where people are now not
starting to talk about the fact that hey
this can actually be good for overall
all of us
from it used to be no win heck I'm going
to talk about this this is something
just you guys are kind of alarmist or
whatever it is you are but now I think
the world is slightly changed in the
last 10 years my senses in the next 10
years it's going to change where the
investment from public and private
sectors are going to start making uh
real inroads into what could be I don't
know 10 years from now we will still be
having the same argument that California
is asking us right now in terms of
charging infrastructure as well as the
fact that you I'm going to go all
electric I think it's going to get there
to be much better
I read somewhere that they said it takes
about 42 billion dollars for some of the
smaller medium duty trucks to be
electrified or something like that in
terms of charging infrastructure in the
scheme of things I think people would
invest 42 billion dollars if there are
some seed monies that come from the
government as well
I think this question this question this
question of who gets it first and you
know certainly the thing with
electrification is the cities versus
rural areas where it's not even about
the wealth of a particular country it's
like in a city you have a density of
people fine someone's going to put in
some charges if you live out on some
little Hill in the middle of nowhere you
know there ain't no charges anywhere out
there
and so it becomes an equity thing yeah
where I am and that Equity is also even
more
important right particularly when it
comes to environmental justice the
places that have the biggest impact are
often indisproportionately in low-income
places and other areas where it is
enormously difficult which means that
more and more we have to start
considering in our sustainability goals
environmental justice as well it is not
just about putting technology out there
are you doing it with the right
environmental justice in mind yeah
and well that sort of leads into a
question here by uh Jeremiah Rhodes
um about which sort of it's I mean all
of these things are related I think that
that what he says is a new
transportation technology adaptations
vary even within different regions of
the United States you know in California
you see electric cars everywhere in
Columbus Indiana they're much less
common do we expect the same thing to
happen in industrial sectors this is
what Jeremiah is asking or for
adaptations to become more uniform as
they become increasingly economic viable
so I guess the question is is there a
Tipping Point where everybody just picks
it up or is it always going to be top
down and it just rolls down the slope I
I I feel I don't know what this is right
or not I have a rule of thumb that it is
between 10 and 15 when a technology
picks up to be at about 15 The Tipping
Point already happens
a good example is natural gas does not
happen we're still in the five to seven
percent when it gets to that point then
there will be more users everywhere and
then it's just self-fulfilling if you
will so that 10 15 is what we need to
look at to say is it getting close to
that once it gets close to that there is
people see money in it and then they
will start coming into it
so we have a couple of minutes left
the push that regulation has on
advancing Global emissions progress so
what's your outlook on legislation
globally for decarbonisation and also
legislation that affects the off highway
or the industrial segment so I mean you
spoke before about the role of
governments but legislation what what's
going on there and what should be going
on yeah and you see in the United States
California has taken the lead which is
what California air resources board and
it's almost like feels like it's a
separate country by itself but that has
proved to be good in terms of Technology
pushing forcing function if you will and
then there is EPA Environmental
Protection Agency that typically follows
suit in terms of the rest of the 48
states or 44 states that they regulate
on and that is one the Eurozone has a
bigger impact I would argue because of
the fact that China India and many of
those other countries follow the Euro
regulatory framework as well in South
America there are some that follow the
Euro regulations and others that follow
the U.S U.S regulations in some ways I I
think these are going to start making a
big impact and they're already starting
to do the Euro seven regulations just
came out last Friday in Europe and that
is advancing existing Technologies and
also they are talking about fuel
averages Fleet averages and things like
that these are all going to start
driving the adoption of new technologies
as well as pushing existing Technologies
to do the work that we need to do now on
the off-road that these folks were
asking it's important as well it's going
to lag but eventually it'll get there as
well
so then just finally a question for you
about sort of the future and how
optimistic you are look because one of
the things I think we do is we don't
paint it we talk about moving away from
things we don't necessarily talk about
what we're moving towards so I was just
wondering if you were to look ahead 10
years for example to imagine the world
in 10 years time you know assuming we do
well at all of this what what are the
most exciting things sort of visualize
that world for us what are the things in
it that we you think we want we should
want to see in 10 years time that we
should get excited about now yeah I I
think school buses are going to be
quieter school buses are going to be
electric and when your kids go in there
you're going to start feeling like the
fact that there is not going to be in
some sort of emissions that they need to
have into it as in some ways transit
buses when you're driving around a city
that's going to be there when you are in
city center it's going to be quieter and
it's going to be cleaner and you're
going to be in ports where there is
going to be old trucks that are there
for 20 years or so there is going to be
newer trucks that are going to be there
in parts of the world like in China and
in India there is a vast amount of
trucks that will be kind of phased out
and new trucks that are going to be
efficient and new trucks that are going
to be with electric or hydrogen is going
to happen these all give me hope that
not only will development continue to
happen but at the same time I think we
are going to be in a cleaner better
place for our grandkids I sure hope that
my grandkid would come up and say that
what did you do in the 20s I actually
made a difference and that difference is
that I made this place Greener I made
this bleach sustainable and I hope
hopefully I left a better place than I
found it
well that is a great place to finish uh
thank you so much it's been a pleasure
to talk to you and to explore all these
issues and thank you to the audience at
the people who ask questions especially
thank you to Intelligence Squared and
cummings and for more more information
about Cummins please visit cummins.com
and that is it so I hope we've given you
some food for thought for the rest of
your day so thank you everyone and
goodbye